are you ready I'm going to press it
Merry Christmas Merry Christmas here you
go Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas the story is about Adam he
lives in an apartment Block in London
he's kind of locked himself away from
the world he has stopped living in any
kind of productive way and one night he
meets Harry so you're looking at me from
this tree I've seen you a bunch of times
coming and going with your head down
Adam and Harry I think they're kind of L
less mirrors each other they both feel
very
isolated this moment Dad they died just
before was 12 I can't even begin to
imagine how Lely he must have been Adam
decides to go back to his childhood home
and we comes across his
parents and he sees them as they looked
when they died so they are now younger
than he
is hi I love that idea of basically
meeting your parents again oh boys back
home is this real does it feel real yeah
there you go
then everybody can relate to that idea
of wanting to go back and to redefine
what your relationship with your parents
was it's about two different forms of
Love sort of familiar love and then kind
of romantic um adult love and how you
those two things affect each other have
you got a girlfriend I'm gay must admit
I'm a bit surprised
not really sure what I feel about it his
parents weren't Angels they were real
people who if they were living now would
be much older and have certain values
inste of beliefs so they have to sort of
evolve as the film evolves sorry I never
came in your room when you were crying
oh really it's okay Dad I get it it was
it was so
long it was so long ago in many ways the
film is about how you integrate pain
into your life you have to find a way to
move on and not let it ruin other
relationships thinking about you all eat
today thinking about watching crappy TV
with you on a Friday night eating take
away your s far I want to go out you and
me together into the
world it's such a lovely concept having
the opportunity to get to correct the
mistakes that you might have made can
now you all right
son while it is personal I think the
story is entirely Universal you promised
me that you're going to try with this
boy hope you make each other a bit
happier the story is incredibly moving
I'm just every day struck by how
heartbreaking and beautiful a story it
is I was too scared to let you in but
I'm here with
[Music]
you